starting off this hour is going to be
Deanna and Fort Benning Georgia hi
Deanna how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up in your
world well um I need some help
I am a divorced single mother of three
children I do not get child support I
have filed half file bankruptcy twice I
am in the beginning of a second one
filed my first one while I was still
married my second one just a little over
four months ago and I pay it it includes
my car and furniture and minor bills
that added up to be a lot of money have
about $60,000 in student loan debt that
is of course currently in forbearance
right now so right now I don't have
anything that I'm putting out with the
exception of what I pay for my chapter
13 my question is I've actually read
your daughter's book and I am in process
of listening to smart money smart kids I
am trying to I've tried to budget and it
hasn't worked yet I did I have not done
it three consecutive months as has been
suggested but I'm trying to find out
where I should start in order for me to
not feel like I'm drowning all the time
money-wise and what's your household
income 32,000 a year from my job and I
am a veteran so
take home around 2200 a month that is
untaxed from that regarding what my VA
disability disability okay all right
what do you do for a living I am a
medical support assistant at the
military base okay and how much do you
owe on your car I was around $10,000 and
how much do you owe on that furniture I
was about six thousand you make $32,000
a year and you about $6,000 worth of
furniture when you have three kids that
years ago before you got divorced yes so
this all survived the divorce yes and
how long ago were you divorced in 2013 I
file it was actually finalized in 2014
two years ago yes okay
$6,000 end up with the furniture I mean
did he not end up with some of the debt
in the divorce he fought the divorce so
the agreement was I left with whatever
was in my name and he left with what was
in his name it was not a healthy
relationship well it wouldn't be a
healthy relationship if you divorced
okay all right huh and you bought the
car after the divorce or before after
yeah well I think the thing that Sharon
and I went through this 20 plus year
almost 30 years ago and the thing we had
to stop and do say okay how did we get
here and and what do we do so that we
don't have to live this way anymore
because life's too freakin short to be
the stressed out right okay so the first
thing we realized was is that payments
are not our friend mm-hmm borrowing
money is not your friend of course and
well you say of course but you borrowed
a $10,000 to buy a car while you're
making 32 well I definitely know it now
yeah okay just making sure
and I'm not trying to beat you up I'm
just trying to say you know you need to
really get to the bottom of this thing
and do an autopsy on it and go well you
know what happened that will cause this
patient to die you know and that debt is
part of the problem here some of it is
surviving from a dysfunctional
relationship
and ship and turning it around and some
of its trying to feed three kids and not
making a ton of money right so there's
just some reality to your math that's
tough to start with but then you've got
to be you know every little mistake you
make is just magnified because
everything's so tight yeah and the
interest doesn't give you any wiggle
room so um like for instance you have to
do a budget you cannot survive if you
don't start writing down where your
money is going to go and then stick to
that you don't have a choice you don't
have any wiggle room for goofing up or
being disorganized it's too tight okay
and it's just you know you've got to be
just crazy disciplined with what you're
going to write down and we're not doing
anything with money except what is on
this paper so number one we're not
borrowing any more money we may need to
sell this car and get it you know to
reduce this chapter thirteen what's in
the 13 other than the car and the
furniture menial small days things like
cable bills old electric bills things
that like I said from my marriage I know
subjectively
I'm not going to suggest on the radio
that you step out of the thirteen once
you're in there because it's too
complicated but but I think you're
probably going to want to work your way
out of that sooner than five years with
all you have been through and all you're
facing five years of paying chapter 13
payments is an eternity and so I really
probably going to get you leave you in
that 13 a little while get some little
things cleaned up and then we've got to
have a plan to get you into a different
car and and you know do something
different with this furniture it may be
settled that furniture bill and then
that just leaves you with the student
loan mess to get out of so number one is
no more debt number two is a tight
budget we'll stay in the thirteen for
now and work our way through that and
then number three is we got to work on
your income long-term your career so how
old are you I'm 35 okay so what are you
going to be doing when you're 45 that
pays eighty thousand well that's what
I'm trying to figure out right now
they looked into real estate mm-hmm
as as an option for myself holder your
children people they are 14 13 and 11
okay and I have started them on a
commission system there's no child
support at all over the last year since
I've had to order I think I've collected
is he military about $500 is he military
- he is not okay
I was yeah you were and you told me that
okay all right so bottom line is is that
I you know we need to do something if
there's anything you can do short-term
to get the end come up it's a heat a
thousand dollars a month right now
changes your life yeah and
mathematically I mean I know that from
listening to you then number two
long-term what are you gonna be doing 10
20 years from now that makes you a ton
more money and you need to start
determining that in determining the 16
steps it takes to get there whatever
they are and begin to slowly take those
steps in the meantime I want to walk
with you you're scared and beat up okay
I want to have one of our coaches sit
down with you I will pay for it and walk
with you through this thirteen and help
you make the decision to win to step out
of that 13 when to get rid of that car
and then the second thing is I want you
to go through Financial Peace University
our nine week class and I'm going to pay
for that - Merry Christmas okay thank
you very much oh my goodness well you
got to go do some stuff different kiddo
because what you've been doing is
brought you into a mess and we got to
help you change direction here this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
now
[Music]